deadly chaos at kabul airport this
morning as security forces try to hold
off thousands of afghans desperate to
flee the taliban german troops were
involved in a fire fight with unknown
attackers that left one afghan security
officer dead and three others injured at
least 20 people have died outside the
airport in the weeks since taliban
militants seized control of the afghan
capital
people coming here risked their lives
the tense situation at kabul airport
erupted early monday morning into more
violence
unknown assailants exchanged shots with
afghan u.s and german military at the
northern gate of the airport
numerous people have already lost their
lives outside these gates thousands are
still attempting to leave the country
and are swarming outside the compound's
fences
at times people tried to enter the
airport any way they could
on sunday seven people lost their lives
in a panicked crash at the gates
there have since been several reports of
missing children after families were
separated amid the chaos
facing a storm of criticism u.s
president joe biden once more defended
u.s efforts to evacuate people from
kabul
good afternoon
there is no way to evacuate this many
people without pain and loss of
heartbreaking images you see on
television
it's just a fact
there have been reports of the taliban
carrying out a door-to-door manhunt
instilling dread in many residents
we want peace we want peace don't we
we've had enough of war
for afghans the question now is what
kind of government will be formed and
how inclusive it will be of its people
and we can cross straight to journalist
franz marty who's been covering this
story for us from kabul france we hear
there's been an exchange of fire between
afghan u.s and german forces and unknown
assailants outside kabul airport what
more can you tell us
indeed german forces confirmed this it
happened shortly after four o'clock this
morning local time i spoke to a source
at the airport inside the airport who
was close by uh he told me it was a
comparatively small skirmish so we're
not talking about like a major gunfight
but of course it's like nonetheless um
tragic uh that at least one man lost his
life um in general uh there haven't been
like uh incidents of this sort before
which is rather surprising uh given the
chaotic situation
now we've seen chaos at kabul airport in
the past week with people desperately
trying to get onto evacuation flights
what is it the tens of thousands of
people awaiting their need most right
now
what would be most needed would of
course be like a better system to like
process these people unfortunately a lot
of the chaos is because like uh people
don't know to which gate they should go
or they go to the right gate but uh it
is clocked or closed so there's a lot of
confusion around
which is sometimes it's a thought of of
afghans who um
go to places where they're not supposed
to be or go to a gate without a proper
documentation just hoping to get somehow
in on the other hand there is also
a problem inside the airport uh
procedures are often not clear or there
are no people to process
the afghans that want to get in or the
foreign nationals that want to fly out
so it's really uh like blame on on every
side uh president pine is right that
it's always a problem to evacuate that
many people but it could have certainly
uh be done better apart from that it
would be like basic needs like uh water
sanitation first aid if something
happens that the people would need there
now us president joe biden has announced
that he may extend his august 31st
deadline for withdrawing all american
troops from afghanistan what's the
reaction to that being in kabul
so far i haven't seen like many crystal
clear reaction uh the problem is the
taliban have already before said
that they kind of hold the united states
accountable to the 31st august deadline
uh remains to be seen if they will like
revise uh this position
on the other hand
there's still like like panic but uh it
might calm a little by a bit down some
afghans who now flock to the airport out
of fear that they only have 10 days to
get out and then afterwards it would
like be closed so uh it might outsource
this fear a little bit um but it's
really hard to tell
now the organization of islamic
cooperation which includes 57 member
states has called for inclusive dialogue
following the taliban's takeover it's
stressing the importance of peace
stability and national reconciliation
how much sway does this organization
hold and will the taliban take any
notice at all
the polymon have already before without
like being probed said like that they
want to have an inclusive government of
course this is just a talking point and
there's a huge question mark how
inclusive this government will be um so
they will if they address this statement
of the organization
they will probably say that they had
anyway this in mind and they will like
endorse this whether they will actually
do it is a completely other question it
should also be noted that the
organization of islamic states had
already before um in the past years like
issued to both sides so the taliban and
the government like statements for peace
and they had little practical effect on
the ground so uh this isn't a game
changer
all right france marty and kabul many
thanks
we're going to bring in dw political
correspondent hans brandt now
hans thanks for joining us um what are
you hearing from german forces about
that exchange of fire at kabul airport
yes that exchange of fire was confirmed
by the german military by the official
account of the german military they
talked about an exchange of fire early
this morning it was somewhere around six
seven o'clock local time i think
and um
as was said just now there was one
afghan security person that was killed
in this exchange uh participating in the
exchange of fire we're not only german
troops but u.s government soldiers as
well
there is no information about what this
uh attack what this exchange of fire
actually involved who were the attackers
in other words all of that is still
subject to speculation
there was a warning from the united
states in recent days that it is
possible that the islamic state
organization
terror organization might launch attacks
in around in and around the airport and
kabul
this is an organization that is uh
opposed to the taliban in a sense a more
radical organization but this is all
just speculation there's been no idea
why this exchange of fire actually took
place
it's being reported as well that two
german helicopters are not operational
right now what more can you tell us
about that and what consequences would
that have on the ground in afghanistan
this is a just one single report from a
german uh media organization uh claiming
that uh
commanders at the german command control
here near berlin have been saying that
the helicopters are in kabul but it's
not clear whether they can actually be
used there
in the sense they are operational in the
sense that they can fly they've been
there for two days already but they have
not really been put into action and the
official word is that that will happen
once the situation allows for them to be
put into action
i imagine these helicopters were also
requested by the united states who are
using
very large helicopters to evacuate
people from central kabul and these are
smaller helicopters more
maneuverable um so i think there will be
some coordination going on between the
germans and the americans to decide what
exactly uh in what situation to use
these helicopters at the moment they
seem not to be in operation
hence hundreds of afghans have now uh
arrived in germany what what more do we
know about these refugees
the official figures are that the the
german uh planes that are in operation
there's six uh military transport planes
that are flying between kabul and
tashkent
that they have now evacuated more than 2
700 people 1 800 of them are said to be
afghani and the others are members of 38
different nations so
there is an operation going on this
morning another plane has been going to
kabul um and once they arrive in germany
the people are being distributed across
the country
dw political correspondent hans plan
thanks so much
now as the taliban consolidate control
in afghanistan two decades after they
were removed from power the group's
leadership appears to be taking shape
some have been part of the taliban since
its creation in the 1990s so let's take
a look at some of the key figures
has been the taliban supreme leader
since 2016. prior to his rise to the top
he spent decades as a strict hard-line
judge and cleric he has final authority
on military political and religious
affairs
abdul ghani bharadha is a co-founder of
the taliban and is now their political
head he held senior positions in the
late 1990s baradar spent eight years in
prison in pakistan after being captured
in 2010. he helped lead negotiations
with the us to withdraw troops from
afghanistan
last year
the deputy leader of the taliban is
believed to be surajudan haqqani now he
is head of the haqqani network in
pakistan and afghanistan and he led many
of their military efforts the haqqani
network has been a fierce opponent of
the u.s president's presence in
afghanistan and haqqani is on the fbi's
most wanted list and is believed to be
behind several terror attacks now the
head of the taliban's military
operations is muhammad yaqub there are
no known pictures of him he's the son of
the deceased taliban founder muller
muhammad omar
now for more on this i'm joined now in
the studio by dw sandra peterson peters
sandra is from dw's research and
investigations team
and has been covering afghanistan for
decades sandra thanks so much for for
joining me in the studio um now the
taliban they were insurgents
now they're in charge of afghanistan can
you tell us how this could happen
well that's the one million dollar
question whether or not they can
transition from brutal insurgency to
governance and service to the people i
mean let's look at the situation in
afghanistan as it unfolds right now we
have an impoverished country land
blocked of 38 million people
in a politically very volatile region
there is
a severe drought affecting the people
hunger massive internal emplacement
insecurity continuing violence not to
mention covet 19 so it really is an
uphill task and for sure the taliban
cannot tackle all of this by
a rule of fear and rule of draconian
punishment that but this is essentially
what they are known for so there is a
need to change
can you just give us a bit more
background um about the taliban i mean
who are they and they're saying you know
they're different now they've changed
have they really changed since they were
last in power 20 years ago well
obviously there are very media assassins
so if you hear them talking especially
to western media you will hear words
like we want to set up an inclusive
government we want to forgive we want to
move on we want to have
a government for the people by the
people of the people but how that can
happen when so many people really fear
them and that track record really
suggests something else suggests um for
instance terror attacks
mainly inflicted upon the civilian
population in the past 20 years i think
to gain that trust and to show a
different face is something completely
different and that is something they
haven't done yet they haven't severed
ties with the al-qaeda network for
instance for all that we know there are
still terror forces inside afghanistan
aligned to the taliban movement aligned
to their lightning offensive
which in the end helped them to
you know occupy kabul and now being on
the winning side of things so it seems
and let's just have a look at mullah
battle you have mentioned him he is the
supreme leader of the taliban but he
hasn't uttered a word ever since the
taliban
took kabul and what we know of him is
that he for instance was one
that supported
suicide attacks as a weapon
against foreign forces but also against
the government and again these terror
attacks mainly
affected the civilian population you
have mentioned sierra jadin haqqani one
of the deputy leaders
and yes he has been accused of one of
the
major atrocities
when it comes to suicide attacks one of
them being most likely the may 2017
bombing in front of the german embassy
destroying the building and killing over
150 people so these are the people we
are dealing with and now we will have to
witness whether or not they can
transition
to really be a government for the afghan
people and that at the moment really
stands with a lot of question marks
seems a far stretch now there's one last
pocket of resistance to to taliban rule
the taliban have tweeted that their
fighters are preparing to confront the
national resistance front which has its
stronghold in panchiya after it refused
to surrender can you tell us more about
that
it is really very difficult to assess
the scope and the scale because
with things unfolding so quickly
what we are lacking is essentially
independent voices on the ground who are
in the region as afghan journalists
cannot cover
what is unfolding in afghanistan a lot
of international journalists are also
leaving the country or are stuck at
kabul airport so what we hear from the
panchayat valley which is that pocket of
resistance is really coming either from
the taliban side or from the resistance
side and there is of course the fog of
war what we know is yes there have been
tentative talks both sides said so but
then what we hear now is that both sides
are also preparing um for war and
for battling it out and it is a valley
that is very difficult to conquer but
then also supply lines
inside the valley with the taliban
surrounding it nearly completely that
were very difficult to hold up for the
time being
two sandra petersman thanks so much for
those really fascinating insights
now many at-risk afghans are still
waiting to be evacuated from kabul
airport now they're mainly interpreters
or contractors who worked for the us for
german or other nato forces but some are
already beginning new lives outside
afghanistan dw washington correspondent
oliver salat visited one afghan
construction worker who managed to fly
out two weeks ago with his family they
were on one of the last commercial
flights to leave before the fall of
kabul
this is mirza's new home
a cousin near seattle opened his house
to mirza and his family of six
like most afghans fleeing the taliban he
fears reprisals
and wants to remain anonymous
for our visit the family waited outside
it's a big concern whenever i talk to my
family members
most people know i'm here and safe in
the u.s but that's a big security risk
for the rest of my family
this is one of the last family photos
taken in kabul
after three years of waiting the former
construction worker at the u.s embassy
was granted a visa a few days before the
taliban entered kabul the family escaped
on one of the last commercial flights
the taliban have proven to be bad people
they've already killed journalists and
people who support international
organizations
i feared that they would kill me since i
worked for the americans
that's the main reason i left
afghanistan
mirza and his family found refuge here
in the state of washington next week
they'll move into their own apartment
within a month he hopes his kids will be
able to go to school
i think we will have a bright future
that's because this place is secure
there's the rule of law and that's the
main thing we are hopeful for
mirza knows he and his family made it
but his escape comes at a high price
his mother will not be able to come to
america
he says it's unclear if he'll ever be
able to see her again
you